speaking of stories that aren't going
anywhere
you know the trans stuff which we end up
having to spend so much time talking
about because it's it's
so i would say um nefarious in the way
it's put its tentacles into everything
so i'll give you the stupid disclaimer
just to start if you're trans
and you're an adult i don't care how you
live i don't care what you wear i don't
care who you marry i don't care any of
that stuff i don't care what bathroom
you go to blah blah blah
that being said i don't think young
children should transition
and chop off their genitals or do any
other things like that you can watch my
interview with abigail schreier if you
want
some more interview some more
information on that and i also think
that um you still have to go to if
you're going to jail you got to go to
the jail that's your biological jail
sort of like if you're playing sports
you've got to play
with the people who are biologically the
same as you that's just how it is
thanks for the numbers here 0.6 uh
percent of u.s adults identify as
transgender so i really want you to
think
about how much time the transgender
argument
takes up when less than one percent
basically a half of one percent
of people identify as transgender that
isn't to say we should
treat those people poorly i don't want
laws against these people and i want
them
to find love and happiness and
fulfillment and purpose and all of those
things
but we shouldn't break the entire system
in honor of that well that seems to be
what we're doing
especially here in california we've got
some info from yahoo news a california
law
allowing transgender inmates to pick the
prison gender of their choice
has come under fire from a women's
rights group citing abuse of
females by men in a letter
to evil governor gavin newsom i added
evil the women's
liberation front accused the state of
violating the constitutional rights
of incarcerated women by allowing men
into their living quarters to prey on
women since the law took effect on
january 1st wlf
has received numerous complaints of
assaulted abused and traumatized women
at the hands of male inmates
transferred into their prisons wolfe
legal director lauren
adams said so let's just be clear about
what's happening here
instead of sending people
to the prison that matches their
biological sex
okay we are now allowing men because
this is where it's happening it's not
happening with a lot of women
that transition to men to go into the
men's prison right that's not going to
end well we all know that wouldn't end
well
so what's happening is biological men
who either
are trans or are perhaps psychologically
confused or are pretending
i don't know we don't know these are
people are criminals and probably have a
series of other problems and
drug use and everything else but i'll
even i'm not even trying to make it
about that
let's just say you're a trans guy you're
a man
who's living as a woman okay that's just
fine but now we're gonna put you in
women's prison and then what happens
violent assault rapes all of these
things
we know these things are happening and
again why isn't it happening the other
way where there aren't women
who are trans men going into the men's
prison and beating the crap out of men
right like that's strange how it never
happens that way right there aren't
an awful lot of girls who transition to
boys and then
crush all the boys in wrestling very odd
very odd
but this shouldn't surprise anybody
because
intersectionality has made everyone
stupid
it has made everyone absolutely stupid
and this is what wokism does to
everything so during the election you
may remember this moment biden was
speaking at some big gay event
and just listen to what he said yes and
by the way
in prison in prison the determination
should be
that your sexual identity is defined by
what you say it is not what in fact the
prison says it is
really think how stupid and dangerous
and pandering and nonsensical that is
but that's let's be clear that was the
man who was
to become the president of the united
states who may or may not actually be
the one in charge
basically saying that what we're doing
here in california is the right thing to
do that you get arrested let's say you
i don't know let's just say you're a
serial rapist you know
serial rapist you raped a couple women
you know you put on a dress
and then you go and they're gonna
sentence you
and they say actually you know you've
got lifetime in jail because you raped
maybe you killed a bunch of women you
know you did some bad stuff and then you
go oh well you know
um it's not what's you know my
biological sex it's not
what's on my identification it's not
because i have
the genitals of a man i'm a woman
and i want to go to the women's prison
well by joe biden
and by gavin newsom and the other
ridiculous people who run
the silly banana republic of california
we're going to send that guy
to a woman's prison you think we got a
problem here
and you see how these stories are
connected like this is directly
connected
to just destroying logic and reason
which is exactly what critical race
theory is so that's what
intersectionality is
it's linking together these opposed
depressions
and within that link it then will
destroy the teachers unions it will
destroy our prisons and by the way once
you destroy teachers unions
and then you just you know in effect
you're destroying our children's ability
to learn
and then you destroy the prisons our
ability to rehabilitate people
uh what what what are you left with with
the society
and none of that should surprise you
because i'll link it back to another
story we did yesterday which is how
the democrats were completely unable
to praise america on july 4th and we've
got people like
you know congresswoman corey bush and
congresswoman maxine waters and
congresswoman aoc
where they just basically couldn't say
anything good about america on july 4.
these people don't think
america is good so they would gladly
have our schools go down
and all our systems go down and burn the
whole thing down so we have work
to do